Canadian Prime Minister Justin Trudeau
this is breaking right now folks they
have found a picture of him in 2001 in
brown face that's right in brown face
take a look at the picture there it is
you're looking at it right now that is
Canadian Prime Minister in brownies in
2001 at an Arabian Nights party while he
was a teacher at a private school
Canada's Liberal Party has admitted that
now and you know Canada is in the middle
of an election right now and this is not
great timing for mr. Trudeau I normally
wouldn't just get some breaking news and
jump on like this because you guys know
I don't like getting caught in the
24-hour news cycle but I thought this
story was so rich with so many of the
things that we talked about here I mean
Trudeau is sort of the essence of sort
of the progressive left and this this
postmodern intersectional world where
he's constantly pandering to every
different group to make it seem like he
just loves everybody when he's kind of
really doing a lot of nothing
and it's like man these are the same
rules that you know they always screw
over people on the right and they never
screw over people on the left but he may
have really stepped in it so he
apparently he's gonna issue a statement
any time now and we'll see what he says
but basically unless he has a full-on
apology and Mia culpa that he did this
absolutely horrible thing which of
course in reality is not a horrible
thing unless he was you know beating or
abusing somebody or you know truly
acting racist let's say while he was
doing this then that might be
problematic but if he was at a party
that was themed Arabian Nights and he
got into this it's like come on
everybody we all know this isn't
something to go crazy over but this is
the new rules that cancel culture plays
by so we have a very weird set of rules
I sent a tweet out about this before
that it's like Roseanne Barr sends a
tweet about Valerie Jarrett she gets
called racist loses the number-one
sitcom in America Calcasieu sends you
know some messages way back when when
he's a 15 16 years old Harvard rescinds
the offer you know this SNL guy I can't
remember his name right now but the
Cenotaph guy
makes a couple jokes they may not be
good jokes bad jokes he may have said
some bad words he loses his job then you
get like Sarah Jang and other New York
Times writers that are now deleting all
their old tweets but they have jobs
Ralph Northam is that his name Ralph
Northam the governor of Virginia am i
right on that one yeah governor of
Virginia you know he gets caught in
blackface from 30 years ago he's a
Democrat so it's okay if he was a
Republican obviously it wouldn't be so
this this competing set of rules that
nobody really knows what the rules are
and how they seem to only go one way or
the other it seems like it's about to
come crashing down on Trudeau but you
know he's got the media and the CBC and
Vox and the rest of them on his side so
he's probably gonna be okay